[Music]  my name is laura ingram i've been at fox  news for 20 years  i was not at fox news  the moment it started but i was at  another network and that network was  having a good time with  fox thinking oh it's not serious it's  not going to last that was a scuttlebutt  and  in the beginning you think you're with a  cool network  and then as time went on  i started watching it and i said hmm  that hannity is really good the other  shows his fox and friends something's  going on here  and it became pretty apparent to me  pretty quickly that it did not have an  identity crisis which  a lot of the other outlets had  fox knew what it wanted to be  and stayed true to its mission  that's the key fearlessness is a  underrated quality fox is fearless